I actually have a question for the guys
yeah would you take a girl okay she's
got okay
what would you guys say is a high body
count hi just give me give me a number
twenty five twenty could we say 20 is
high yeah okay that's like medium high
yeah um okay so let's say anything over
the foot is really high okay so let's
say 25 yeah okay her body counts 25.
um however she's never she's never okay
she's never gone back to an ex ever
or you can date a girl that's had five
but there's one X she's been sleeping
with on and off
for seven years that's a good question
on every relationship that ends that's
the guy she goes back to oh yeah she's
done she's over with it no which would
you pick which would I pick yeah I know
and please don't say anything you got to
pick one it's only fun this way
tell me the first one again so she's 20
she is her body counts 25 yeah
um again all things equal looks
everything else is equal one girl's body
counts 25 she's never gone back to an ex
the other girl's body count is five
I'm picking the X I'm picking I'm
picking the one with 25. 25 yeah that's
wild yeah so you would pick the X yeah
because I mean I'll tell you why yeah if
she keeps going back to the same guy
she's kept going back to the same guy
after the breakup yeah yeah if she keeps
doing that um is it only after the
breakup or she's been is a funny
business going in between
um you don't know this is just bro you
know there has to be an emotion if I if
I actually believe
that that she's only going off but back
to that X after the breakups yeah then
I'll go with the one with five and the
boyfriend 100. but
I would have to really trust her yeah I
I don't know why
I feel like the one that's more
dangerous is the one that keeps like the
situation because I've heard girls who
say there's a situationship for six
years yeah it'll be on my mind that's
why I said that but I'm saying if we've
built up that level of trust if we've
spoken about it and I you know I I don't
trust it I hardly trust anybody to be
honest wow so why yeah
anyway so so no but like I would I would
choose if we've got a certain level of
trust and also part of me would believe
that like you know I you know
I'd read Alpha widower
that would be my my Outlook anyway I
might not be right but I wouldn't be
threatened by the way
what if he was Michael B Jordan
um
[Laughter]
yeah but like yeah
is because he chose Laurie Harvey yeah
right and Lori Harvey had been passed
around the industry
I'm not even gonna say a bad word
against him
his choice in women is skewed yeah he's
got he doesn't know he's doing yeah
one thing I just want to say between the
two women that you described for me the
analysis is actually one of them is
actually a tester and the other one is
an investor the the strategy some yeah
it goes back to pick up Artistry but the
women have personality types some women
are testers and some women are investors
some women go out with multiple men just
to find the one that is the closest to
the one that the ideal their ideal man
whilst other men other women go out with
one guy and invest in him in order to
make him the guy that they actually want
and the first one with the five and
keeps going back to the old uh ex-girl
boyfriend is the investor type who is
trying to get this guy to become the one
that she wants whilst a woman with 2025
plus she's a tester she'll test you out
if the next guy comes your monkey branch
and and you so so to make clear I picked
the right one
yo folks let's just say I want to thank
everyone for coming through we have been
on air for a couple of hours now you
know we've already had one person leave
um it was too late I'd like to say she
didn't like she didn't Pearl Castle
herself
I knew what now Pearl Castle I've never
I've never done it but you never know it
could be I've been getting less patient
lately Power Castle that might be a
thing
um but yeah thank you all for coming
um we're gonna thank you wrap the show
up now
um before we do wrap the shop can I just
get everybody's final thoughts on the
subject we'll start over there
yeah I don't have any final thoughts I
think I've given quite a descriptive my
thoughts in quite detail throughout the
show
um yeah thanks for having me no problem
thank you
um yeah can I just plug yeah you can
find me I've just reached a thousand
subscribers on Parham shroomboli so go
there and find me there what's that
what's that it's my YouTube channel
and also I'm on Twitter and I don't have
Instagram yet uh but as far as the final
thoughts are concerned
men who are the average guy pretty much
I I think I fit the mold on that
um yes do look elsewhere unfortunately
the West has has is gone it's it's a
lost cause Western women whether you
think their their trades or not they are
feminists no matter what they say to you
feminism is the cancer that has already
seeped into the West it's a lost cause
go to Southeast Asia or or the Middle
East I thought you said you didn't
struggle here you said in your no no no
no no for marriage sorry sorry for
marriage for for Pump and dumps Europe
is your golden ticket
all day every day feminism is the
greatest thing that happened to a man
who wants to get laid Yeah
yeah
but but if you want to get married look
elsewhere because I think Europe is done
I'm sorry
not a virgin and you're a single mother
do not go and curl up in a quarter and
die
you don't have to pump and do
but it's been it's been amazing it's
been really insightful it's been really
good like hearing who hurt you opinions
yeah that that's my final thought
I think I think ultimately women in the
west are
brought up differently to women in other
countries they're brought to be
independent and sort of to fight for
equality whereas other women in
different cultures are brought up to
serve the man I'm not saying that's the
sole purpose of what a woman's job is
but that's that's you know woven into
their characteristics and DNA so it only
makes sense that if you're looking for
someone who's going to be submissive to
you're going elsewhere if you're being
logical
um at the same time on the flip side I
understand the gripe of the women
criticizing the men because
as a black guy if I saw a group of black
women promoting we're leaving black men
to go to white women or whatever
different racism well sorry white man
here excuse me I would understand
lesbian how I would feel
um if it's about publicizing it and
making it a movement so I can understand
that somebody's
irritation towards a group of men
um making a movement basically but yeah
that's my final thoughts on it well I
thought that was well
um
I would say
on both sides of the spectrum it's fine
if you're a guy that's having a lot of
trouble
if you're just like super mediocre or
below mediocre and you're having loads
of trouble you can't be bothered to
work on your social skills and by all
means go abroad and there's literally I
don't think you deserve a judgment for
that to be honest right however
if you don't want to travel all the way
to another country because you like it
where you are and you just want to
improve
I would say
go on the internet look at loads of
videos or if you want to save yourself
some time
and my YouTube channel is the rmbz
original and uh if you want to go on my
link Tree on my Instagram you can get an
empowerment call with myself right but
also guys and girls you know always
remember that we have to love each other
we have to try and make it work right
and
um I just like Terence said you know I
can understand why women will be you
know feel a certain way about guys going
to another country and making it a
movement
but women
come on man you got to be a bit nicer to
the to the normal guys out there man you
know because a lot of the women that are
being less than kind to these normal
guys
are also normal women
and and you know we all have a lot of
baggage and we just need to give each
other a lot more understanding
remember Aaron bz on Instagram
so I decided today I want to do a final
thought yeah
but today I decided I'm going to so
um first of all I understand why they're
leaving and I think as modern women we
should try to learn from the women
overseas and ask what they're doing
right and what we can do to keep them
this day rather than shaming the men
that are leaving um I think they have
their reasons and if men are going to a
different country we're probably doing
something wrong so we should probably
pick it up
um second off about being a single
mother it's not over if you're a single
mother if you're really hot
[Music]
it probably is over because this is what
I heard from the mat and this is me I
don't make the rules I just tell you
what they are I guess if you're an a if
you're an a each kid is at least a point
subtracted so you you automatically is
sick so if you're an eight maybe a nine
you might get away with it if not tough
luck um I would maybe learn to cook or
maybe do some other skills maybe get in
the gym I don't know but it's gonna be
tough to compete with the single
childless women like me out here anyway
job
but I thought you couldn't work on these
things so then put yourself in a place
did you not hear me talk about wife
school yeah yeah
basically get a BBL on diet train okay I
mean you can't you can't get rid of your
child
not after you birthday
my final thoughts are this
um follow me Sarah Garvey on all uh
social medias and
um yeah I actually think that men who go
abroad to find love
um are probably doing the right thing
because I don't think that Western women
generally
given feminism and all the other isms
and schisms
um are the best women to be with so yeah
guys if you want to get your passport
passport Bros go get your passport fly
out to Dominican Republic Brazil
Philippines Thailand South Africa East
Africa wherever you go
grab your passport and go um I
personally went to Kenya and uh
and um yeah um other than that uh if you
ever watched two or more of our videos
tell them and you have not subscribed
then we have Whopper beef what have we
got beef exactly so you better get doing
that right now thank you all for joining
and let's get Sarah to 100 000. yeah
let's get me to a hundred thousand
Goldman YouTube man and get me to 100K
come on guys and girls as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible